et
[Musique]
françois bayrou bonjour bonjour merci
d'être mon invité ce matin vous êtes
patron du modem vous êtes le maire de
pau vous êtes haut commissaire au plan
on arrive au bout de ce quinquennat ce
quinquennat on l'a presque oublié mais
au début vous considériez d'ailleurs
emmanuel macron l'a reconnu lui même que
c'est à vous qu'il le devait qu'il
devait son élection à votre engagement
décisif à ses côtés cinq ans plus tard
on va voir s'il enthousiasme est
toujours intacte je voudrais d'abord
vous interroger sur la question de la
démocratie vous en aviez fait un de vos
chevaux de bataille nouveau décompte
aujourd'hui par le conseil
constitutionnel du nombre de parrainages
au moment où on se parle il n'y a que
trois candidats qui peuvent être
officiellement candidat il s'agit de
valérie pécresse d'anne hidalgo et
d'emmanuel macron marine le pen n'a à ce
jour que 139 parrainage valider si elle
vous demande françois bayrou de l'aider
à avoir ces parrainages est ce que vous
direz oui alors faut prendre la question
globalement s'agit pas de tel ou tel
candidat
on est dans une situation de très grand
risque à mon avis que vous en souvenez
peut-être j'avais
sur laquelle j'avais averti il ya déjà
plusieurs semaines
cette situation est que un certain
nombre des candidats et même un nombre
certain de candidats de premier plan
dans cette élection
représentants des intentions de vote
très haute
10-15 plus de 15% des voix sont menacés
de ne pas recevoir le nombre de
parrainages ce qui les empêcherait de se
présenter pour moi c'est une situation
de très grands risques voyez bien notre
démocratie
de risque de quoi de risque de maurice
franceschi initiale ont le sentiment de
ne pas entendu de ravoir s'exprimer de
risque de déstabilisation de risque de
perte de confiance de sentiment que
l'élection ne sera pas sincère qu'elle
peut être changée par
pour moi c'est un risque immense n'est
ce pas quand vous atteignez 10 millions
10 % par an dans des sondages
c'est trois millions et demi
d'intentions de vote est ce que des
candidats qui sont à ce niveau là
peuvent être écartées de l'élection par
le mécanisme des signataires voudrait
dire près de 4 millions de français qui
ne pourraient pas s'exprimer oui et
peut-être 8 ce qui vient plusieurs
candidats qui sont dans ce cas là et
cela pourquoi on voit très bien parce
que les mères j'en suis un ont le
sentiment que la publicité qui va être
faite à leur signature va être
interprété comme un soutien à des
candidats
dont ils ne veulent pas apparaître
comme étant co responsable alors qu'est
ce qu'on disait alors l'idée que je
propose c'est que des maires se
regroupent pour dire nous nous sommes
prêts à examiner cette situation
et s'il manque des signatures nous
sommes prêts regroupés que nous sommes
sans soutien politique en disant que
c'est ni partisan ni soutien politique
nous sommes prêts à rebours et partir
entre nous le les signatures nécessaires
banque de parrainage oui c'est une
banque de parrainage démocratique ces
parrainages comme c'est pas voyagé et
j'ai ce mouvement là je propose qu'on
l'appelle notre démocratie on peut aller
on va créer un site où notre démocratie
points marquants parce que j'imagine oui
ce matin on a en a jusqu'au 4 mars et
tous les maires qui sont intéressés par
cette démarche qui consiste à dire nous
sommes les garants de la démocratie
nous sommes prêts à porter des
signatures pour que les gens puissent se
présentait pas pour les soutenir pas
pour dire que nous sommes d'accord avec
eux
ce notre démocratie point fr ce
mouvement là à qui on peut écrire dès ce
matin en mettant tout simplement notre
démocratie point fr contact
@ notre démocratie point rêva disant ça
y est c'est très précis mais il faut
bien faut bien qu'on fasse des choses
précises et et sérieuse
je ne sais pas si on peut y arriver mais
au moins on aura essayé en tout cas moi
je je ne peux pas supporter l'idée que
la démocratie soit ainsi déséquilibré
déstabilise s'en dissocier la couleur de
ses candidats à plumes pardon d'être
précise mais est ce que ça veut dire que
au moment où on se parle vous considérez
que les mères qui vont donc qui ont la
charge de sauver la démocratie
qui vont rejoindre votre mouvement
pourront ensuite donné si marine le pen
si eric zemmour si philippe poutou
demain ou jean luc mélenchon a besoin
général critères pour moi il ya un
critère simple c'est ce qu'ils
atteignent 10 % dans les sondages parce
que 10% ces quatre millions vous voyez
bien qu autrement il ya des
multiplication de candidatures comme à
chaque élection qui paradoxalement
trouvent les signatures alors qu'ils ne
représentent pas un mouvement important
des français pensent à kieran hidalgo
par exemple elle a déjà c'est signé
c'est top c'est un très bon exemple du
déséquilibre des candidats qui ont leur
signature et qui sont cependant
extrêmement loin d'atteindre un seuil
critique mais le vous voyez bien
je ne suis pas
de la vie politique de jean luc
mélenchon de marine le pen de zemmour
franchement ce n'est pas mon courant
politique mais je trouverais anormal et
même scandaleux qu'il ne puisse pas se
présenter je pense que la démocratie ces
jeux je veux que les opinions
s'expriment même si je suis en désaccord
graves profonds avec ce qu'il ait pas ce
matin ils peuvent concrètement rassurés
ils auront leur signature grâce à vous
pas grâce à moi ce n'est pas un
mouvement partisans il faut que ce soit
trans partis et avec beaucoup d'élus
s'ils s'amusent ils vous ont laissé ces
mères j'imagine que vous avez cette
conscience
existent et se développent parmi les
élus garant de la démocratie faut que ce
soit trans partis et même sens du modem
qui vont sûrement
d'abord je suis pas sûr que chez nous il
n'ya pas de caporalisation que je
décroche pas mon téléphone pour donner
des ordres c'est pas comme si ces
projets sont les femmes et c'est pas
comme ça que ça se passe mais vous voyez
bien le risque qui existe vous voyez
tous les mouvements on a eu les gilet
jaune mais il y en a beaucoup d'autres
qui que j'essaie de comprendre
je je vois bien le ce que les
commerçants par exemple ressenti ils se
sentent assiégés empêchés de faire leur
travail je vois bien les mouvements qui
se prépare sûrement parler dans un
instant et donc mais je voudrais
j'essaie de comprendre ces mouvements là
qui sont à beaucoup d'égards très très
déstabilisant ces mouvements là ils
viennent de ce que la perte de confiance
dans la démocratie est générale il faut
rétablir cette confiance et les
institutions font que ce sont les maires
les élus tous les élus qui en sont des
gars qu'ils puissent voter avoir le
sentiment que ceux qui les représentent
puisse se présenter françois bayrou
avait vous donnez vous votre parrainage
donc pour l'instant non vous pourriez le
mettre en jeu dans ce dont sa banque
bien qu qui je soutiens je jeu mais
précisément je souffre
oui absolument les foudres parrainage
pourrait aller demain à marine le pen
dont eric zemmour dans deux semaines ou
trois semaines deux semaines on verra ce
qu'il en est peut-être ils vont trouver
peut-être vont-ils trouver l'homme ici
il n'arriva pas français
je compte pas mal de contacts at notre
démocratie voilà notre démocratie point
fr c'est de cela dont nous avons la
charge et je le dis avec beaucoup de
j'essaie de le dire avec beaucoup de
prudence parce qu'il faut pas que ça
apparaisse comme des mouvements
récupérables
les élus les maires les conseillers
régionaux de bain
de france et d'outre-mer tous ont le là
ont la certitude
qu'ils ont quelque chose de précieux
entre les mains ce quelque chose
aujourd'hui mon sentiment je me trompe
mon sentiment est que c'est terriblement
fragile et que si l'un de ces candidats
qui recueillent beaucoup d'intentions de
vote qui portent des sentiments ne peux
pas dire que je n'aime pas
empêché de se présenter alors il y
aurait je couds si c'est très important
sur une audite calme ce matin parce que
ça fait des semaines et même des années
qu'on nous parle de ce feuilleton
régulier décider des fameux parrainage
si je vous écoute au fond à partir
d'aujourd'hui ce problème est réglé au
titre non mais ce qu'ils méritent de se
présenter ceux qui ont une assise
suffisante dans l'opinion française et
parmi les votants pourront se présenter
à pauline de malherbe c'est réglable
vous dites c'est réglé c'est un
mouvement complètement inédit ça ne
s'est jamais fait ça ressemble un peu à
la proposition que j'avais faite d'une
banque de la démocratie exactement qu'
on puisse garantir que les candidats
pourront se présenter gym m6 devrait
prendre deux exemples très précis quand
même françois bayrou l'un c'est que
emmanuel macron à les 500 signatures ça
y est ce que est ce que vous dites
finalement au maire qui peuvent être
même de la sensibilité des manuels
macron arrêter de parler ça ne sert plus
à rien puisque ça y est les à ces
signatures garder vos signatures en
réserve dans votre tiroir
aujourd'hui je n'ai aucune envie de
faire de
mais je vais au bout de la démarche à
votre micro j'ai aucune envie de faire
de la polémique ni de priver manuel à
condeissiat c'est les arias je devrais
bientôt mérite oui mais vous voyez je
trouve que la démocratie on en parle
comme de quelque chose qui est extérieur
à nous en réalité nous en sommes membres
nous en sommes les garants tous les
citoyens les journalistes les
responsables politiques jésus traitement
conscient les élus sont
parties prenantes
coresponsable cette co responsabilité
cl ce que je crains arrivait on peut
laisser prendre ses responsabilités vous
avez évoqué de vous même ces mouvements
qui parfois le sentiment de ne pas être
écouté deux solutions donc l'une c'est
permettre que ce qu'ils puissent les
représenter puisse se présenter l'autre
c'est peut-être aussi de pouvoir
manifester on apprend à l'instant que
les convois de la liberté ces fameux
convoi qui sont d'inspiration
canadiennes qui ont commencé à converger
vers paris seront interdits de
manifestation
c'est le préfet de la police de paris
qui vient de l'annoncer pour trouble à
l'ordre public est ce une bonne manière
on ne peut pas accepter que la vie soit
bloqué les la vie et la ville la vie et
les villes on peut pas accepter que un
courant d'opinion minoritaires
empêchent les autres de vivre et quand
bien même serait-il majoritaire ce
serait la bonne chose est enfin là on
les empêche de manifester et non
il ils ne pourront pas bloquer les
villes et singulièrement pas la capitale
bon moi je trouve que c'est la
responsabilité des pouvoirs publics de
garantir l'ordre de fait qu'on puisse se
déplacer qu'on puisse faire ses courses
qu'on puisse demander aux commerçants
cieux je suis très frappé comme je
voulais dit j'essaie de comprendre ce
qui se passe dans l'esprit des
manifestants des de ceux qui rejettent
en bloc le système
mais je vois aussi ceux qui en sont les
victimes dans une ville comme pau
les commerçants sont exaspérés par la
situation tous les samedis depuis un an
ils sont empêchés dans leur travail ils
ont été en tout cas pendant les
manifestations des gilets jamais ils le
sont les manifestations père diot n'ont
jamais cessé une fois ou deux fois par
semaine ces manifestations bloc et
quelquefois agressivement donc il faut
intervient et donc il faut maintenir
l'ordre le le rôle de l'état est de
garantir l'ordre aimez-vous dernier
précise effet que vous pourrez vous
déplacer la question de la course la
conscience françois bayrou quand vous
entendez hier le porte parole du
gouvernement qui annonce que le pass
vaccinale pourrait être relevé fin mars
début avril fin mars début avril c'est à
dire juste avant les élections ceux qui
sont anti passe peuvent quand même avoir
décemment en tout cas ils vont se dire
forcément abat donc c'était électorale
et puis maintenant c'est électorale
aussi de lever vous voyez bien que je
n'étais pas électorale temps ça a
provoqué de réaction c'était responsable
et je ne sais pas si cette
responsabilité est allée à son terme
quand je regarde les chiffres de
contamination et les chiffres
d'hospitalisation vous voulez maintenant
vous le maintien driller peut-être un
peu plus lentement en tout cas je suis
depuis très longtemps acquis à cette
idée que nous n'avons qu'une seule
réponse c'est le vaccin ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il empêche totalement les
contaminations mais ils empêchent
majoritairement la dégradation de l'état
des malades en réanimation en cas graves
et en décès il ya
infiniment plus proportionnellement de
cas graves chez les non vaccinés que
chez les vaccinés et dont vous êtes
responsables de l'état vous êtes
responsable de la société vous dites
nous avons une réponse elle est reconnu
par tout le monde comme une réponse
efficace évitant les accidents eh bien
on fait en sorte que cette réponse soit
le plat plus utilisés possibles françois
bayrou 137 milliards de bénéfices pour
les entreprises du cac 40 en 2021 c'est
l'estimation faite par nos confrères de
bloomberg bnp paribas 9,5 milliards
l'oréal 4,6 milliards et on l'apprend ce
matin total plus de 15 milliards
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait est ce qu'on
doit laisser les entreprises décider de
ce qu'elles en font ou est-ce qu'il faut
que l'état s'en mêle et 19 maintenant il
faut rembourser une partie ou en tout
cas participer si cette manière ces
entreprises là je pense qu'il va y avoir
des initiatives prises j'ai parlé avec
le président total il
il pense en effet à la question qui
était évoquée sur votre plateau du plein
du il a renoncé donc 5 euros par 50
litres du coup du plat c'est c'est une
cette annonce est une réponse mais ceux
qui prétendent vouloir de grandes
entreprises et empêcher ces entreprises
d'avoir des bénéfices pour investir
pour rémunérer leurs actionnaires c'est
vrai mais pour investir cela ne voit pas
le
les règles qui sont celles de la
compétition mondiale
je sais bien je veux plus être choqués
mais je vais vous le dire c'est une
chance pour la france d'avoir de très
grandes entreprises comme ça de très
grandes entreprises qui sont capables de
supporter la compétition la recherche le
les voies nouvelles dans lesquels il
faut investir ça coûte beaucoup d'argent
malheureusement nous n'avons pas réussi
on a sorti un rapport du plan hier sur
le médicament nous n'avons pas réussi
dans matière de vaccins être les
premiers mais ç'aurait été mieux que
nous le soyons et donc le l'idée qu' il
faudrait regarder tous profils
d'entreprise que m'étant
condamnable moralement
cette idée n'est pas celle généralement
des initiatives c'est à dire qu'au fond
vous ne vous ne poserez pas vous
n'impose riez pas ceci est une autre
question le plénum a l'air vous avez
utilisé mon initiative oui ça veut dire
que au fond vous vous attendez à ce que
les entreprises censé pas seulement je
pense que pour la france la très grande
question sur laquelle je m'obsède depuis
décennies depuis des temps déjà le
lointain c'est celui de la reconquête de
la production
il se trouve que nous sommes un pays
vous avez vu les chiffres du commerce
extérieur
dont lequel nous 5000
s'éjecter où nous nous sommes laissés
éjecté de secteurs entiers de la
production production industrielle
production agricole production
intellectuelle sur ce que je pense
tout ce qui est le logiciel
chargé rares et professeurs chercheurs
nous nous sommes laissés éjecté
je pense qu'on peut inverser le
mouvement et je suis sûr que c'est
l'idée du président de la république
dans le plan 2030 auxquels nous avons
participé
elle a relancé sur mer et le nucléaire
une question immense imminente et qui
peut donner à la france un avantage
considérable on ne pourra pas réussir
cette reconquête
si on ne met pas autour de la table
c'est le sens au fond de votre question
les pouvoirs publics les grandes
entreprises celles que vous évoquez les
grandes entreprises mondialisées qui
réussissent sur sur le champ de la
planète
les petites entreprises les pme enfin
tout ce qu'ils peuvent participer à ce
sujet c'est pourquoi nous avons avec
commissariat au plan nous avons analysé
poste par poste le déficit du commerce
extérieur on a regardé ou
1914 poste où on a plus de 50 millions
de déficit par an on admire regarder où
on pouvait agir et ma conviction est que
cette reconquête là il faut que l'état
soit à l'initiative mais que les grandes
entreprises et les pme soit autour de la
table pour être partie prenante du grand
élan qui fait qu'on se fixerait comme
meubles qu'on se fixera j'espère comme
objectif de de reconquérir la production
qui lit vos notes
président de la république le premier
parce que c'est auprès de lui est ce que
vraiment il s'en saisit parce que ça
après vous vous dites il m'écoute
d'abord c'est pas cinq ans après parce
que le commissariat au plan dès le début
du quinquennat ou vous avez commencé à
faire un mondial il n'y a aucun doute
qu'ils s'en saisisse peut-être pas sur
tous les sujets que j'ai mais l'immense
majorité des sujets je prends un exemple
cette question du nucléaire le
commissariat au plan publié il ya
quelques mois un peu moins tenant une
note stratégique qui déploient ou
développent un raisonnement simple
on a besoin d'électrifier un très grand
nombre d' usage
pour les déplacements les mobilités la
vois tu ne l'ès pas la consommation
contraire on l'augmentera
et la maison toutes les rencontres que
j'ai fait avec les organisations de
défense de l'environnement tout disent
il faut électrifié très bien dès
l'instant qu'on dit ça comme en
produisant l'électricité vous sentez
écouter oui on sait vraiment pas où je
crois comment produite l'électricité
il ya du renouvelable mais si on est
objectif le renouvelable à soi seul ne
peut pas
satisfaire
les éoliennes vous voyez les polémiques
qui a le photovoltaïque blocage de très
grandes surfaces vous allez redoutent
aujourd'hui sur l'éolien sur le vote
allemand sur trois ne peut pas tout
miser dessus quoi ça on ne peut pas tout
faire comme ça parce que l'éolien c'est
par nature intermittents l'éolien le
solaire parfois y'a du soleil parfois y
en a pas du vent il y en a pas il y en a
où il n'y en a pas et il faut à côté de
ça des productions pilotable comme on
dit c'est à dire capable de remplacer le
rhône ou
presque le nucléaire est aussi un peu
intermittents puisqu'au moment où on se
parle ya quasiment 12 réacteurs ils
savaient pas à l'arrêt parce qu'ils
n'ont pas été suffisamment non entretenu
ils l'ont été il ya une autorité de
sûreté nucléaire mais parce qu'on n'a
pas fait les investissements à temps les
investissements qui vont annoncer ce
sujet elle m'a que nous avons devant
nous c'est le rattrapage comment un
grand pays peut-il rattraper 15 20 ans
de retard sont pas tout à fait due au
hasard il y avait des lobbys qui ont
empêché qu'on fasse le travail et il ya
d'autres lobbys qui ont permis cru
relance peut-être françois barrault
merci d'avoir répondu à mes questions ce
matin vous l'annoncer avec notre
démocratie point fr vous voulez
permettre que les candidats qui
représente une force dans ce pays
puissent tous se présenter nous sommes
le nous sommes dit ce jeudi 10 février
et c'est précisément deux mois avant le
premier tour des élections